[Music]  [Music]  okay yeah  go to the forest no Jesse sugar  yes he's everywhere you can stop  [Music]  leave her alone  [Music]  the map why do you seek this it's only  brings death you are death what else  dears  so what does that map really of we're  here the Seven Cities of Gold  Sir Walter Raleigh drew this map after  he found one of those cities so how does  the witch she's the legend kept  everybody from coming out here looking  we're gonna need more supplies I guess  we're not going home  that's dammit there's something in their  bloodstream  [Music]  hey back off for those ladies the  Cypress who the White Witch  one reason they think you're a threat to  the witch you're in danger  a few ladies  it's green because no one's gonna hear  you  you're welcome for that girl I was gonna  ask you the same question we have to go  under the journal and find out  Vic Judah otherwise with yourself  you  you